[Music]
the technology enablers are now there
and we're going to be making that
transition just as we are into
self-driving cars into things like
digital currency transactions without
hardly even noticing it for example when
you buy that cup of coffee at Starbucks
and you pay on your mobile phone it
could be that the application program
interface in your phone last week
flipped from using your bank account to
a payment system based on digital
currencies and you might have gotten a
brief notice with five pages of fine
print saying I agree at the end and as
long as you hit that button you just
made that transition without noticing it
I think it could be it at the consumer
level as quick as that that's not to say
that it's simple hundreds of billions of
dollars of Technology software and
hardware
need to be built around this
particularly software and a lot of legal
work and a lot of regulatory work and
the central banks have to go along with
it before it'll be allowed because it's
a concern it's part of the money supply
and central banks will be responsible
for monitoring that and there are some
countries that are thinking about it
China Sweden those are two countries
that are currently contemplating
introducing digital currencies at the
national level through the central banks
of those countries so change is coming
and I'm very interested in studying the
implications of that change
[Music]